WWDC is less than a week away and we've
recently been getting more and more
leaks which confirm that Apple's 15-inch
MacBook Air will be coming on Monday so
in this video I'll quickly go through
those new leaks and then answer a very
important question that you need to
decide before WWDC should you buy the
new 15-inch air or just wait for the new
M3 13-inch MacBook Air because those
leaks have also changed recently as well
so let's jump right into it on May 1st
Mark German finally came out and boldly
confirmed that Apple will in fact be
releasing the 15-inch Air at WWDC and
then on May 4th we got reports from
digitimes that suppliers are stockpiling
the new model to prepare for the big
launch and then on May 20th Morton
Stanley reported that quanta computers
started ramping up MacBook production
and the second quarter of this year
which started in April which hints at a
new Macbook are getting released so with
those three recent leaks and everything
prior to that I can say that the 15-inch
MacBook Air is coming for sure 100
guaranteed at WWDC but now let's get
right into the whole question of buying
the 15-inch air right away or waiting
for the M3 MacBook Air I recently made a
video exploring the possibility of the
M3 chip being delayed until the spring
of 2024 for various reasons including
issues with three nanometer chip Supply
and the fact that Apple has a stockpile
of M2 chips that haven't been selling
too well which is one of the reasons why
the 15-inch air is coming with an M2
Chip and that's already been confirmed
by digit times Mark German and minxi quo
so one big reason to just go with the
new 15-inch air is that you can get it
next month instead of potentially
waiting until next year if the M3 does
in fact get delayed however that might
actually be a good idea for some people
to wait so let's get right into the
comparison but first I've gotta show off
her sponsor into Hill's 16-inch portable
4k monitor which is perfect for
professional users especially MacBook
and Mac Mini users looking to do things
like graphic design video editing 3D
modeling or anything else featuring a
thin aluminum design dual speakers a
bunch of ports like USBC and HDMI an IPS
panel with up to 10 bit color depth and
a magnetic case with a stand so whether
you already have a Macbook or you're
waiting to buy one of the new ones click
the link in the description below to
check it out now getting back to the
15-inch MacBook Air versus M3 MacBook
Air comparison the first thing we need
to discuss is the most important which
is the chip as we know the 15 inch is
getting the M2 which was known as a
stopgap chip when it came out it seems
like it's just an overclocked and tuned
up version of the M1 chip with some
faster memory and some other changes
made but it's almost the same yes the
performance is an upgrade for sure but
it's not big enough to warn people
buying the M2 over the M1 purely for
performance reasons now the big reason
for that is that the M2 is still a five
nanometer chip just the second
generation I believe that from the very
beginning the M2 was planned to be on
tsmc's three nanometer but then that got
delayed so they just went with this
stopgap method with the M2 and they
delayed the real Three nanometer version
until the M3 chip now the M3 that we are
going to be getting is going to be very
fast in terms of the performance do due
to the efficiency improvement with the
performance per watt a big jump in
efficiency and battery life I also
already estimated and calculated the
performance of the M3 chip using leaked
a17 scores and it should be very very
good even potentially faster than the
current Bend M2 Pro chip but that was
just a prototype maybe it is going to be
a little bit slower than that but it's
still extremely impressive now one thing
we know for sure is that the 15-inch
MacBook gear we're getting next month
unfortunately will not be getting the M3
it's going to stick to the same M2 Chip
so be aware of that however the M2 is
still a good chip and more than good
enough for most people out there it's
just a mental upgrade kind of thing now
the big issue actually comes with the
SSD setup of the M2 Max like the M2
MacBook Air where Apple decided to use
only a single and Flash chip for storage
which dramatically reduced the
performance of the SSD swap memory when
your RAM is full so consider upgrading
to 16 gigs of RAM or a 512 gig SSD if
you go with the upcoming 15 inch which
is likely going to have the same setup
with the nand flash now on the other
hand with the M3 MacBook Air there is a
chance that Apple changes their ways and
packs in two Nan chips again hopefully
they do that and that would instantly
fix the issue with the SSD swap now
moving further keep in mind that when
the M3 MacBook Air does come out it'll
likely only be the 13 inch display size
so if you want the larger display then
definitely buy the 15 inch MacBook gear
as soon as it comes out next month I
believe there's a chance that Apple sees
the 15 inch air as a mid-cycle release
so we might not see a 15 inch M 3
MacBook Air bottle until the end of 2024
unless Apple completely holds off on
that and releases both a 13 and 15 inch
MacBook Air size together with the M4
MacBook Air models in 2025. now another
important thought is that the battery
life will be insane on the 15-inch M2
MacBook Air probably having the best
battery life ever in any MacBook however
the M3 air coming later might be so
efficient that it could potentially
match this same battery life even with a
smaller 13 inch size now moving on from
that the 15-inch MacBook Air Model
coming next month is likely going to
have a larger track pad which is more
convenient it's going to have larger and
better speakers which is common on the
larger model MacBooks right now the
large display will also be really really
nice for media consumption and things
like editing photos videos rendering any
other productivity work and and the
large display will make the bezels look
even thinner than it already does on
this machine however don't expect
anything else that's special on the
15-inch M2 MacBook Air compared to the
current M2 model they're going to be
almost identical in terms of the
features and specs maybe it'll get
Bluetooth 5.3 and Wi-Fi 6E but we don't
know that for sure but then on the other
hand the M3 13-inch MacBook Air coming
later is likely going to be very similar
to this one in terms of the design since
it just got fully redesigned however
there is a chance that Apple adds in
some upgrades that we're not expecting
like maybe they're going to add face ID
authentication or even 5G cellular
service but none of that has been
confirmed it's just been rumored so we
don't have anything concrete just yet
and now the final thing to consider is
going to be the price I personally
expect the 15 inch air model to come in
around 200 more expense offensive than a
similarly spec 13-inch MacBook Air Model
including the later M3 which I think is
going to stay the same price 11.99 as it
currently is so that basically puts the
price of the 15 inch air at 1400 for the
base model and 1600 if you want to
upgrade either the storage or the RAM
and that could be a tough pill to
swallow since right now on Amazon you
can get a base M1 MacBook Air for only
800 literally half of that price you can
also find a refurbished M2 13-inch air
on Amazon for only
939 dollars which is a great deal if
you're looking to budget but of course
the 15 inch air is going to be awesome
since the larger size will make it seem
impossibly thin and the display will
make it so much more useful so in my
opinion if you don't care about saving a
little bit of money and going with those
great deals on Amazon I I think the 15
inch air will be really special and
it'll be a great laptop to buy for many
years to come even if it doesn't have
the latest three nanometer M3 chip it's
still going to be more than good enough
so let me know your thoughts Down Below
on the 15 inch MacBook Air and click
that Circle above to subscribe for more
videos like this one definitely check
out our other WWDC videos right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign